so what if there were a highly obvious
problem right in front of you one that
everyone was talking about one that
affected you directly would you do
everything within your power to fix
things before they got worse don't be so
sure we are all much more likely than
any of us would like to admit to miss
what's right in front of our eyes and in
fact we're sometimes most likely to turn
away from things precisely because of
the threat that they represent to us in
business life in the world so I want to
give you an example from my world
economic policy so when Alan Greenspan
was head of the Federal Reserve his
entire job was to watch out for problems
in the US economy and to make sure that
they didn't spin out of control
so after 2006 when real estate prices
peaked more and more and more respected
leaders and institutions started to
sound the alarm bells about risky
lending and dangerous market bubbles as
you know in 2008 it all came tumbling
down banks collapsed global stock
markets lost nearly half their value
millions and millions of people lost
their homes to foreclosure and at the
bottom nearly 1 in 10 Americans was out
of work
so after things calm down a little bit
Greenspan and many others came out with
a post-mortem and said nobody could have
predicted that crisis they called it a
Black Swan something that was
unimaginable unforce evil and completely
improbable a total surprise
except it wasn't always such a surprise
for example my Manhattan apartment
nearly doubled in value in less than
four years I saw the writing on the wall
and I sold it so a lot of other people
also saw the warning spoke out publicly
and they were ignored so we didn't know
exactly what the crisis was gonna look
like not the exact parameters but we
could all tell that the thing coming at
us was as dangerous visible and
predictable as a giant grey rhino
charging or right at us the Black Swan
lends itself to the idea that we don't
have power over our futures and
unfortunately the less control that we
think we have the more likely we are to
downplay it or ignore it entirely and
this dangerous dynamic masks another
problem that most of the problems that
we're facing are so probable and obvious
they're things that we can see but we
still don't do anything about so I
created the grey rhino metaphor to meet
what I felt was an urgent need to help
us to take a fresh look with the same
passion that people had for the Black
Swan but this time for the things that
were highly obvious highly probable but
still neglected those are the grey
rhinos once you start looking for grey
rhinos you see them in the headlines
every day and so what I see in the
headlines is another big grey rhino and
not a new highly probable financial
crisis and I wonder if we've learned
anything in the last 10 years so if you
listen to Washington or Wall Street you
could almost be forgiven for thinking
that only smooth sailing laid ahead but
in China where I spend
a lot of time the conversation is
totally different the entire economic
team all the way up to president xi
jinping himself talk very specifically
and clearly about financial risks as
grey rhinos and how they contain them
now to be sure China and the US have
very very different systems of
government which affects what they're
able to do or not and many of the root
causes for their economic problems are
totally different but it's no secret
that both countries have problems with
debt with inequality and with economic
productivity so how can the
conversations are so different you can
actually ask this question not just
about countries but about just about
everyone but the auto companies that put
safety first and the ones that don't
bother to recall their shoddy cars until
after people die the grandparents who in
preparing for the inevitable inevitable
the ones who have the eulogy written the
menu for the funeral lunch my
grandparents dead and everything but the
final date chiseled into the gravestone
but then you have the grandparents on
the other side who don't put their final
Affairs in order
who don't get rid of all the junk
they've been hoarding for decades and
decades and leave their kids to deal
with it so what makes the difference
between one side and the other why do
some people see things and deal with
them and the other ones just look away
so the first one has to do with culture
society the people around you if you
think that someone around you is going
to help pick you up when you fall you're
much more likely to see a danger as
being smaller and that allows us to take
good chances not just the bad ones for
example like risking criticism when you
talk about the danger that nobody wants
you to talk about or taking the
opportunities that are kind of scary so
in their own way our gray rhinos
so the US has a very individualist
culture go it alone and paradoxically
this makes many Americans much less open
to change and taking good risks in China
by contrast people believe that the
government is going to keep problems
from happening which might not always be
what happens but people believe it they
believe they can rely on their families
so that makes them more likely to take
certain risks like buying Beijing real
estate or like being more open about the
fact that they need to change direction
and in fact the pace of change in China
is absolutely amazing second of all how
much do you know about a situation how
much are you willing to learn and are
you willing to see things even when it's
not what you want so many of us are so
unlikely to pay attention to the things
that we just want to black out we don't
like them we pay attention to what we
want to see what we like what we agree
with but we have the opportunity and the
ability to correct those blind spots I
spend a lot of time talking with people
of all walks of life about the gray
rhinos in their life and their attitudes
and you might think that the people who
are more afraid of risks are more
sensitive to them would be the ones who
would be less open to change but the
opposite is actually true I found that
the people who are willing to recognize
the problems around them and make plans
are the ones who are able to tolerate
more risk good risk and deal with the
bad with risk and it's because as we
seek information we increase our power
to do something about the things that
we're afraid of and that brings me to my
third point how much control do you feel
that you have over the grey rhinos in
your life one of the reasons we don't
act is that we often feel too helpless I
think of climate change it can feel so
big that not a single one of us could
make a difference so some people go
about life denying it other people blame
everyone except themselves like my
friend who says he's not ever going to
give up his SUV until they stop building
coal plants in China
but but we really have an opportunity to
change no two of us are the same every
single one of us has the opportunity to
change our attitudes our own and those
of people around us so today I want to
invite all of you to join me in helping
to spark an open and honest conversation
with the people around you about the
grey rhinos in our world and be brutally
honest about how well we're dealing with
them I hear so many times in the States
well of course we should deal with
obvious problems but if you don't see
what's in front of you you're either
dumb or ignorant that's what they say
and I could not disagree more if you
don't see what's in front of you you're
not dumb you're not ignorant you're
human and once we all recognize that
shared vulnerability that gives us the
power to open our eyes to see what's in
front of us and to act before we get
trampled
[Applause]